the eastern Mediterranean energy
Leadership Summit in Athens on Tuesday
was dominated by Cyprus two years from
now the Mediterranean island is aiming
to join neighbours Israel and Egypt in
being energy independent and an exporter
of natural gas that's not going down
well in Turkey it wants an agreement
with the islands Turkish Cypriot
community on how the energy wealth will
be shared
Turkish ships are exploring for oil and
gas within the area Cyprus has
demarcated as its exclusive economic
zone some experts predict the political
insecurity will hamper development using
gunboat diplomacy in raising the threat
of escalation and war
it makes it impossible for any rational
actor like companies to make the
long-term investment Turkish troops
invaded Cyprus in 1974 in response to a
Greek coup attempt on the island Turkey
controls more than a third of the
divided island where the Turkish Cypriot
minority lives a political settlement
remains elusive with the Republic of
Cyprus dominated by Greek Cypriots the
Cypriot government is offering to open a
bank account to deposit 30 percent of
oil and gas revenues for Turkish
Cypriots until a political agreement is
reached but turkeys government says that
is a unilateral change to the status quo
we kept warning the Greek Cypriots
do not take any unilateral steps which
would a infringe on Turkish continental
shelf rights be on the rights of the
Turkish Cypriots on the North because it
is not enough to say look don't worry
I'm going to give you a share of any
proceeds Turkey also disagrees with the
area Cyprus is demarcated with its
neighbours saying it should be a lot
smaller if we accept the Turkish version
of the Cypriot exclusive economic zone
we will be left with 31% what it
actually is today
all of the discoveries in Cyprus so far
will all fall in other countries and and
I think turkey must first answer the
question how is that in the interest of
Turkish Cypriots much is at stake
according to the United States
Geological Survey the eastern
Mediterranean holds 350 trillion cubic
feet of natural gas and three and a half
billion barrels of oil that alone is
enough to power the entire European
Union for 20 years at the moment Cyprus
Egypt and Israel stand to share most of
those resources and turkey has none of
them the overarching question is whether
Turkey will demarcate its maritime
interests according to the international
law of the sea like its neighbours or
raise the temperature further john
psaropoulos al jazeera athens